hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
we're gonna start off with a game called
good night which is your typical go into
a haunted house try to solve the mystery
and then try not to die we usually end
up dying anyway so
hua
you are driving in a secluded place
when a storm comes in
oh oh i am
[Music]
any particular reason why
this storm doesn't seem to calm down i
need to find a shelter
you're goddamn right i do
i probably shouldn't leave my bike here
but
i don't know what shelter i'm gonna find
is that a house on haunted hill
yeah good thing i dumped my bike there i
never would have made it up this hill
hello
can i get shelter here
this place looks so creepy and abandoned
but i have no choice
i mean i got self-responses i mean yeah
i have a choice but what do you expect
okay good point there pal good good
point all right good point good point
good point good point very good point
all right well better turn this house
into a home
it ain't so bad
it just needs a little love
you know i hope this storm will stop
probably never will
not a whole lot going on
i'm sorry
what was that what was that indeed
hello oh my god
hello
anyone there
that's it i would rather continue
driving and get wet than stay in this
place
uh is that a good idea
am i seeing goodnight
oh
i see
oh oops oh my bad hang on hold on hold
on where's my mouse my mouse is gone
where's my mouse give me my mouse
where's my mouse
hello mouse mouse is gone one second
hold your horse what was noise
ah
okay hello anyone there is anyone
somebody
hello
doesn't seem to be anybody
well
a whole lot of nothing i say
a whole lot of nothing
oh my god i swear i heard a footstep i
hear it a footstep i sure did buddy i
sure did
no you're not crazy that was definitely
a footstep
oh
hi
hey
how you doing
what the hell is yeah what the hell is
that hey you get out of here i saw
to be continued oh did a leaf on quite a
cliffhanger well
it's not bad
it's not good
but it did make me jump and that's all i
can really say about it but if that was
your first game not bad i'm not going to
complain about it i'm not going to
complain about it i'm not complaining
about it well done support that
developer
okay what
this game uses procedural turnip drop
technology
why does it do that
welcome to overtime
right click to zoom
i did it
oh
hi there this is gary from internals
sorry that's not nearly gary enough hi
there this is gary from internals i'm
just calling to remind you of your
meeting in 15 minutes it's nothing bad i
promise
just a little chat
but don't be late alright
uh
are you there
it remains silent hello
oh shoot must have missed them must have
must have gary
oh
asks i go meeting now
oh there are actually other people here
hey
what's going on what's happening nice
soup uh them beans i love beans
oh hey
you reached to pull the door open but no
matter how hard you pull it stays shut
there's no response from the figure
inside recognize this probably means you
shouldn't go in and leave or keep trying
fine keep trying
yes
all right boss
just go on my way wherever this meeting
is hey what's up what you got there
smokes ah it's a usb drive
it's about to say thought you quit oh
all right you're having a tough time
i'll leave you b
hey what's up steve
guy on break
hey
all right whatever
fine
this is the scariest game of all cause
the nightmare of corporate
whatever
it looks in insert something clever
attend meeting on floor g1
but what's up there i don't know why i
always do this but i'm always curious
uh you know what for the first time i'm
gonna go exactly where it tells me to go
and i'm definitely not gonna miss
anything secret
definitely not
definitely not probably yes i probably
did goddamn it i probably did but
whatever it's fine
meeting these offices really are all the
same huh
still where is everyone are they all on
break
well i don't know
where is everyone
um
this is where the meeting was meant to
be but there's no one here did i get the
time wrong
um
well
check the ah check the time oh clock
man i'm real good at these objectives oh
my god what happened what happened what
happened oh
i didn't see that
what
jack black
uh what was that this one i just uh no
it's just the stress getting to me i'm
bleeding for my eyeballs better get back
to my office quickly yeah i better
yeah i'm gonna
oh yeah i'm gonna
return to your office and
masturbate
oh my god
hey steve
hey
oh sorry
my apologies man i'm on break if you
need something i'll be back at my desk
in 15.
oh sorry
you're not even from my department
it's been a little hectic recently
silence is golden
okay and maybe i'll talk to you
oh i lost my chance okay well that's
what i get for being silent i guess i
should understand that i'm kind of an
axe there's a strange feeling
again return to your office
[Music]
what
oh my god oh
i don't know if there's fall damage in
this game but it probably wouldn't be
best to do that um
okay
yeah i'll go back to my office
well that don't sound right
hey
how's that flash drive it's gone
oh
chips
all right you still working on that
super pal he's gone
okay whatever i'll just go to my desk i
guess
where was my desk
hello
oh finally i've been trying to reach you
for hours
hi gary why the no show
the
right you're talking about your
disciplinary meeting
that you didn't show up for
despite me calling you beforehand
multiple times
it's not a good look you understand
i've been sitting at my desk this whole
time waiting for you these excuses just
won't cut it i'm sorry you're a good guy
but it has just been one thing after
another with you
hasn't it
i'm gonna have to ask you to head up to
hr
right now
okay yeah something ain't right
but it's probably me
all right i'll go up to hr then
huh it's jammed
oh my god
hi josiah
hey
where you headed
oh big trouble huh
you've been doing something you're not
supposed to
i'm just messing with you
better get going
yeah okay all right i
man you have broad shoulders i can't i
can't make it by you okay goodbye
to hr i go
that's finance
and
board room number two
human resources
all right
oh
well that's different
um
convenient flashlight it sure is
convenient
boy i don't like human resources
this is what hr looks like all the time
for those of you who have not been
called into an hr meeting it's uh
it's not meant for this world
okay good
seems like something is blocking it
great
oh good
[Music]
i eat the competition
okay
well
this is unsettling
i'm not even gonna bother wait maybe
there's a motivational poster that i
could see you we are not culpable for
any workplace related deaths
call poppable
oh that was a oh oh oh oh monster
okay i'm not going to read into that oh
my god
josiah
all right you seem fine
um
what happened to your josiah
well this is kind of awkward huh you
uh weren't meant to see all this
but i figure you can guess where this is
going now huh hey oh whoa whoa wait wow
no need to tell me twice
this is why i spoke
[Music]
oh hey
your phone's been going off for like
five minutes i took off the receiver so
to stop hope that's cool
you look totally out of it sleeping on
the job
i had the strange dream where you
stabbed everyone to death yeah
you were in it oh
whoa uh yeah that's cool that's totally
cool
dude
well uh
we can catch up later don't you have
some meeting with gary in 15 minutes or
something
oh
i like that i did it was a little slow
on the movement and the movement was a
little clunky but as far as like theming
goes i'm always into these type of games
where it's kind of like a weird dreamy
alternate reality nightmare stuff also
set in corporate america always good
time always a good time but
moving on
welcome to interstate buffet
i'm get oh i'm guessing it's an
interstate buffet
damn i'm quick
am i skiing hell yeah
oh
uh sorry i'm farsighted apparently
physics interesting
oh
haven't seen a loading bar in a while
sounds busy hope i can get a table well
i suppose i could wait uh man i wish i
could read
okay please be seated be back in 10
minutes why is that like that
why would that be i can see myself just
fine oh there's no one here
i'm seated i sat i sat
i sat
god i'm blow okay
what
is that screw it i'm gonna go get food
yum let me escape
yum yum
yum yum there's nothing left oh
yeah that's fine you can't take food
without a plate ah
i'm so sorry i have a plate now
oh
oh ah
[Music]
okay
ah
ah okay
whatever this a lighter yep
um
some cookies
the change you started already have
far-reaching effects be ready
advice is like kissing it costs nothing
and is a pleasant thing to do
change has happened in your life so go
with the flow
person is never too old to learn your
infinite capacity information will be
ordered
later the night life is for you
oh
hi
okay uh
you know what that didn't qualify as a
single game so i'm gonna just
fire up another one here you get a four
scary games because man i'm just having
too much of a good time
good stuff man all right this is can i
have a glass of water your classic fair
where your daughter asked for a glass of
water in the middle of the night i think
that was the story behind it
daddy can i have a glass of water maybe
sure thing sweetheart
you got it
my daughter wants water i get my
daughter water
oh god
a good thing i have a flashlight i could
turn lights on but that might wake her
up
why does this look like the resident
evil house
the green lights will guide you good
thing i put those in
hello good thing i put that in my house
what
okay
probably fine how big is this house
this does look like the resident evil
house
is it
hey sweetie
you want water i don't have it um
just kind of exploring my house
don't mind me trying to figure things
out
anyway water you got it
you got it 100
definitely
oh cop
cop
wobber
it's a big cup
all right i'm going back up to get your
water
here you go
[Music]
you know what we've talked about the
green light by your bed
thanks dad
you're welcome you're welcome now sleep
very peacefully
can you shut off my light too
sure thing
i would love to
wait a minute
i don't have a
[Music]
[Laughter]
the daughter
no one saw coming i can't believe they
did that one they pulled that card wait
a minute
i don't have a daughter so what's real
too the the kids room the house itself
was this all the nightmare what is it
what is it all right so that is it for
three security games
four scary games thank you everybody so
much for watching slightly losing my
mind but that's okay look in the
description for a special surprise that
you've never seen before it's right down
there below the video click show more
oh you are going to love it
links to the games it's linked to the
games in more scary games also it's a
link to my podcast distractible that i
do with bob and wade you know bob and
wade bob wade good friends of mine we
make a funny podcast it's mostly just us
jabbering on endlessly about our own
inane which i know you guys
love and as always i'll see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]